let's get back to the phones where many
of you are waiting to speak to me we do
these calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go we are going to try again
our good friend eric from cancun eric
welcome let's hope your connection is
steady today
hi david gomez
gracias
um the thing i'm going to tell you last
week is that do you know the concept of
falcons racer yes i do occam's razor of
course
because first of all in philosophy a
racer is when you want to get rid of an
unnecessary theory when you want to
explain something and you don't want
complicated explanation so british will
and malcolm going to explain that the
simplest explanation is the correct one
if it gives a better or the same results
as the other complicated ones yeah eric
can i explain it in a slightly different
way
um
for example no no but eric what i'm
saying is would you allow me to give my
explanation of occam's razor is it okay
if i take 15 seconds and do that okay
okay
the way i think of occam's razor is
if we have two competing explanations
for some phenomenon
and
both explain the phenomenon equally well
but one requires fewer assumptions and
is generally simpler
we would tend to favor the simpler
explanation that's how i think about
occam's razor eric if that's okay
um yeah the simplest explanation for
where to fly is that he flaps his wings
and becomes lighter than air the
simplest explanation for a boat to float
is that its shape can create a vacuum of
air that makes his float because he is
then less dense than water the simple
explanation for biden to be present is
that in 2020 everyone started to hate
trump because of being awful
and i think that that concept would
balance out the whackiness of the
internet and social media
and i heard that concept in my
philosophy class also from my dad and in
one episode of the simpsons when every
all the adults were drinking the erotic
tonic that homer and they were selling
and the kids were wondering why their
parents were keeping them out of the
house while they were doing the
hanky-panky lisa said that maybe because
they are reverse vampires they must go
home before dark wait a second eric is
that a simpsons episode or you're saying
your dad has an erotic tonic that he
drinks
that's from the second part is from matt
simpson's episode my dad also told me
about the concept of alkans racer and
also my philosophy class
that's beautiful eric you've really said
it all today
and it's because conspiracy theories
want to feel like james bond or any
other super spy from the movies but
instead of learning how to hack enemy
computers and martial arts and looking
good with a martini and a tuxedo they're
making fun of themselves don't you think
i agree with you completely i agree with
you completely eric remind us how old a
guy are you
i'm i'm 30. 30. okay all right eric
great to hear from you i appreciate it
still good the weather in cancun is
still beautiful as always i assume
it's a bit cloudy right now would you
prefer if i'm your weatherman or your
guillermo
i actually like hearing about the
weather in cancun it really lightens the
mood
if you want to come might have a good
airbnb place if you want okay yeah let
me follow up about that okay
hey i'll give you an email thank you bye
all right there is eric gonna hook me up
with an airbnb in cancun love it
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes